In today's video,
we're testing if diamonds
really are forever.
What happens if we
try to burn one?
[Music]
Previously, on this channel,
we've showed you
how to make liquid oxygen
by taking liquid nitrogen,
putting in an
insulating container,
and letting it
just evaporate off.
Once the liquid nitrogen
has boiled off,
you're left with a very
small amount of liquid oxygen,
which is a very cold,
very pale blue substance.
We should get a little bit
in each of these eight cups.
And we already set these
up to start letting
the liquid nitrogen boil away
because it takes at
least an hour to do,
and we've gotten it to the point
where it's boiled
down most of the way,
but we've still got at
least 30% left, I think.
Hopefully, over the
next 15-20 minutes,
that will boil off, and we'll
get that pale blue liquid
Calli was explaining about.
That should be liquid oxygen,
and we should be able
to just combine
that all into one cup
once we're done,
and hopefully, do
some cool experiments with that,
and our three forms
of carbon that we have.
Pencil graphite,
charcoal, and diamonds.
All three of these types
of carbon are things
that we see and use
in our regular days,
and they all have
pretty different properties.
Charcoal, of course,
comes from burning wood
in a low oxygen environment,
and graphite and diamond
are both naturally
occurring forms of carbon
that are mined from the ground.
So, while diamonds are
still as far as we know
the hardest substance,
they're actually weaker
than graphite in one way.
The atomic structure
of a diamond is formed
in a three-dimensional lattice,
whereas a graphite
is actually formed
with tightly bonded sheets.
Now, it's actually
kind of interesting
because at a chemical level,
graphite is stronger.
However, in practical
use and size,
and a way that we're
going to run into,
you can crumble graphite
with your fingers, you can crush
charcoal with your hands.
With diamonds, you're going
to need something stronger.
I don't think I could crunch
a diamonds no matter
how hard I tried.
I mean, you could try.
That'd be entertaining
for all of us.
It's just not going
to go anywhere.
So, once our liquid oxygen
is finished forming,
we can start doing experiments
with our three forms of carbon
and that liquid oxygen to see
how they react.
Here's the basic idea.
We have three different
types of carbon,
and we want to see what happens
if we burn them
in liquid oxygen.
All right, guys,
time for a quick update.
We had our cups full of liquid
nitrogen, trying to extract
oxygen out of the air,
and how much did we get
out of that, Calli?
That would be none.
Zero.
Like not even a drip
down at the bottom.
Absolutely none out of that.
So, we decided to scale up
to a suddenly more industrial
oxygen farming technique.
We brought in our friend
Alexander to show us
>> how best do that.
>> Hello!
Alexander, tell us
just a little bit
about your experience
in this field.
Well, I am currently
studying engineering
at the University of Utah,
and sometimes,
we do demonstrations in which
we might need liquid oxygen.
And so, the method
that we use is we use
an industrial oxygen tank,
and then, a little bit
of liquid nitrogen.
It turns out
that nitrogen boils
at about 77 Kelvin,
and oxygen boils
at about 90 Kelvin,
which means we can use liquid
nitrogen to condense oxygen gas
and form liquid oxygen.
So, right here,
we've got, this is
just a coil of copper.
It was like 10 bucks
at the hardware store.
We then wrapped it
around a piece of PVC pipe,
being very careful
not to kink it anywhere
so there is still
smooth flow all the way down.
So it comes in
through this hose here,
and then travels all the way
down to the bottom coil here.
And this part is submerged
in the liquid nitrogen?
>> Yes.
>> Correct.
That's what freezing
the oxygen.
Then, this comes
up back and hooks,
and so, we'll have
liquid nitrogen in this,
this gets submerged down
into the liquid nitrogen,
and you can see it's just got
a little fountain spout,
and we're just going
to pour that right
into our styrofoam cup.
So basically, the idea is
oxygen gas comes in here.
This entire length
of copper tubing is going to
cool it down about 300 Kelvin,
and then, right at the bottom,
it's going to have
the right temperature
that it will condense
into a liquid,
and the back pressure
from the oxygen gas
will pour it out.
We'll get a nice little fountain
of very pale blue liquid pouring
down into our styrofoam cup.
And that's when we
can really start the fun.
So let's pour
some liquid nitrogen off,
and then turn on
our oxygen tank,
and get this fountain going.
Most of the bubbling
has settled down.
I mean, they're still
bubbles coming out of it,
but it's settled down
to the point where it's
not like exploding all over,
which means our copper has now
been cooled down by quite a bit.
All right, so we're going
to start the flow of oxygen,
and then, we should start
to see in like 10 seconds
a nice pale blue liquid
coming out of the spout.
Just clearing the line, I think.
Yep.
So right now,
we're cooling the oxygen
down about 300 Kelvin,
and then as soon as it gets
to that temperature,
and we get a sufficient
amount of it,
it will start pouring out
into the cup here.
Awesome.
Okay, so we can start to see
little bits of liquid oxygen.
Oh my gosh.
And now we're starting to get
a more consistent flow.
You can see as the oxygen makes
contact with the copper here,
the frost recedes back
because it's actively
cooling it again.
So one milliliter
of liquid oxygen expands
to about 860 milliliters of
oxygen gas at room temperature.
What you're seeing here,
once we've filled up
this cup is really
quite a significant
quantity of oxygen gas.
So 1/4 teaspoon of it
would provide enough oxygen gas
to fill like a two-liter bottle
or one liter bottle.
Yeah.
Let's check this out.
We now have a big old cup
full of liquid oxygen.
It's a nice pale blue shade.
If I stick my finger
in it real quick,
it's going to freeze my glove,
pretty much the same way
liquid nitrogen does.
It's also significantly more
dangerous than liquid nitrogen.
So, liquid nitrogen, basically,
the worst it can do
is freeze your skin
and give you cryogenic burns.
Liquid oxygen can do
that as well,
but it can also help things
become extremely flammable.
So oxygen gas itself
is not flammable.
That's a pretty
common misconception.
Things like propane,
hydrogen, those are flammable.
Oxygen gas is important
in sustaining fire though,
and right here,
we have a cup of very,
very concentrated oxygen.
The oxygen in the air
around us is about 21%,
and obviously, the air
isn't very dense.
This is about
as dense as water,
and it is 100% oxygen,
which means that it
will allow us to make things
that aren't normally
considered very flammable
burn extremely well.
We've got some
liquid nitrogen here.
We've got a clear cup,
and I think we want to use
the clear cup do this in
so we can see things
a little bit better.
But we don't want to lose too
much of our liquid oxygen,
so we're going to use
the nitrogen to cool this down
before we put the liquid
oxygen into the cup.
[Music]
That's so pretty.
Yep.
It's a beautiful pale blue color
because it absorbs all
of the red wavelengths
from the atmosphere.
Is that--
Wow.
I did not know that.
Yeah.
So the quantum notation
for that is triplet sigma gerade
oxygen molecule goes with,
added to the product
of Planck's Constant
and the wavelength
that you're going to absorb,
then goes to a singlet delta
gerade oxygen molecule.
You lost me a triple
singlet stigmata?
This is charcoal.
Charcoal is almost
entirely carbon.
It's not going to be 100% pure.
There's going to be residue left
from the wood, gas,
and stuff like that,
but it's mostly carbon.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to get this burning,
and then drop that down
into our pure liquid oxygen.
And it's not going to explode.
No, it shouldn't explode.
The oxygen is going
to be stoichiometrically
in a very high excess.
So it should burn very
readily and very bright.
But it shouldn't explode.
All right.
Here it goes.
We're trusting you, Alexander.
Just gonna hit
this little tiny piece
of charcoal with a blowtorch.
Here it goes.
Yep, so you can see,
even though it's currently
sitting in a cryogenic liquid,
it is still burning
very, very brightly,
and that's because there's lots
and lots of heat being formed,
and that charcoal
is currently being converted,
and it's now been all converted
into carbon dioxide gas.
That's cool.
And there is no residue.
>> No.
>> There's nothing left.
Since its acting
in a pure oxygen environment,
there's going to be
nothing left but gas.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
By the way,
the super awesome slow
mo footage we've got today is
courtesy of Kuma Films.
This is amazing.
>> So even...
>> Look at the sparks.
Even just right
as it was falling in,
like at when I was
at the top of the cup,
first filling in
for the first time,
it was pretty dull.
By the time it
reached the surface,
it was already glowing brighter.
So you can see it's just in
the higher oxygen environment.
It hasn't even hit
the liquid yet,
and then, it
does hit the liquid,
and just goes crazy.
That's gorgeous.
That is fascinating.
The balance yet,
and then all
the sparks that come off.
It's like a
personal firework show.
It really is.
Fireworks in a cup.
Next up, we have our slightly
more ordered form of carbon.
This is graphite
that has been pressed together
into the shape of a pencil core.
We broke a piece out.
We're going to try
and burn this,
drop it into the liquid oxygen,
and see if there's anything
different about it
than the charcoal.
[Music]
In.
It's not really doing
as much as I thought.
Maybe it wasn't hot enough.
Interest--
Well, it's bouncing around.
It's not stopping though.
It's still reacting.
Is it going out?
But only the part
that's outside.
Yeah.
It went out.
[Music]
We didn't get any reaction
out of the graphite,
and it's possible that
our torch wasn't hot enough.
It's possible that
the configuration of graphite we
pulled out of a pencil is maybe
a little bit the wrong formula,
but there is one more type
of carbon that we want to try.
Diamond.
That's right.
So, we have some diamonds.
Calli, where's our diamonds?
Okay, look.
Fine.
Okay.
I believe, total,
I was wearing 1/8 of a carat.
1/8 of a carat
of very low grade,
but still diamond.
Still counts.
That's glowing pretty nicely.
Glowing orange.
That is our,
the tip of my forceps.
What happened to
our last diamond, Nate?
What'd you do to it?
I burned it up.
So, I was using these forceps,
and they were very cheap,
and my torch actually
started to just melting them.
So I was having a really hard
time holding onto the diamond,
and I kept dropping it,
and then one
of the times I dropped it,
there was just nothing
left to pick back up.
So, here we go.
I'll try not to burn this one
up until I drop it
into the liquid oxygen,
at which point, I hope
it burns up spectacularly.
Cool.
It's already cool.
Awesome.
>> Oh my Gosh.
>> Yeah.
There we go.
It took some doing,
but it started naturally burnt.
Shine bright like a diamond.
It's a new meaning to that term.
[Music]
That's so much cooler
of an ending than most diamonds
are going to get.
Can you destroy diamonds?
You can destroy diamonds.
Innumerably many ways,
but this is probably
the most fun.
We're just gonna show--
I'm not actually
going to drop this in.
I'm just going to hold it.
Oh, well.
Just right over the top.
Just that oxygen
rich environment.
That's just charcoal
burning at its fullest.
[Music]
This has been really cool.
Alexander, thank you
for your expertise.
Kuma Films, thank you so much
for the amazing slow mo shots
that we got today.
It looked amazing.
Beautiful.
Amazing.
Guys, Kuma Films,
they've got really cool stuff
on their channel.
Go check that out.
[Music]
Guys, thanks for watching.
Click up there to check
out our last video.
We'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.